vielleicht waren sie schon bekifft oder
betrunken oder sie haben eine nacht
durchgetanzt und haben gemerkt der
rausch hat seinen reiz einige gehen
weiter probieren lsd oder pilze und
versuchen so eine ganz neue sicht auf
die welt zu bekommen was fasziniert uns
menschen also am rauschen wann beginnt
die sucht und was verbindet den
höhenrausch eines bergsteigers mit einem
lsd-trip diesen fragen gehen wir nach
jetzt in der sternstunde der nacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie langweilig ist doch die realität
warum auf dem geraden weg der vernunft
bleiben wenn faszinierende ausflüge in
eine andere welt locken
ausflüge in ein verändertes bewusstsein
[Musik]
vom austrinken über party pillen vom
dampfenden jeans bis zu lsd und heroin
die auswahl der substanzen kennt keine
grenzen
mal sollen sie entspannen mal antreiben
oder befreien
mal werden sie gefördert mal sind sie
verboten einige machen süchtig und krank
die unterscheidung zwischen genussmittel
heilmittel und droge scheint nicht immer
klar
der chemiker albert hofmann entdeckte
1938 in basel eine substanz mit namen
lsd
damit löste er eine weltweite forschungs
euphorie aus wie er sich später erinnert
für aktive verbindung medizin biologie
der experimentellen psychiatrie als sehr
nützliche wertvoll ihrer schnelligkeit
und erst wurde das lsd verwechselt -
mittel
die protestkultur der 68er nahm die
halluzinogene mit begeisterung auf es
war die hohe zeit der psychedelischen
drogen
doch bald machten berichte von psychosen
und tödlichen unfällen unter lsd
einfluss die runde
1971 wurde der stoff in der schweiz
verboten
von nun an galten halluzinogene
substanzen als gefährliche und illegale
drogen
seit den 90er jahren fluten neue
synthetische pillen den schwarzmarkt
zusammen mit lsd kokain ecstasy und co
bevor sie den partyrausch am wochenende
[Musik]
doch im zeitalter der hirnforschung
kommt die hoffnung wieder auf
halluzinogene könnten uns zugang zum
rätsel unseres bewusstseins verschaffen
wissenschaftler untersuchen ob diese
substanzen gegen depressionen und andere
psychische störungen wirksam sein können
besonders im trend bei forschern wie
konsumenten das sogenannte micro dose
kleinste dosen etwa von lsd sollen uns
leistungsfähiger und kreativer machen
was fast sie mit uns am rausch geht es
um entgrenzung kontrollverlust ekstase
suchen wir nach verlorenen göttern oder
nur uns selbst braucht es zwingend
substanzen um in solche zustände zu
geraten
willkommen sind so sternstunde dann auch
schon sind sie dabei und herzlich
willkommen auf meinen ersten beiden
gästen bei uns ist milan scheidecker er
ist arzt und neurowissenschaftler und er
erforscht unter anderem seit vielen
jahren den therapeutischen nutzen von
psychedelic was das genau ist werden wir
später noch hören und bei uns sich
trainer harry ist blogger und
kommunikationsberater
sie haben während 15 jahren ganz
unterschiedliche substanzen ausprobiert
so ziemlich alles was es gibt oder gab
sie haben
tollkirsche ausprobiert schmerzmitteln
lsd zauber pilze und schlussendlich dann
auch heroin sie waren am platzspitz sie
haben auch den letzten miterlebt in der
stadt zürich und dann auch die
schließung des setzen
sie waren 14 auf das ganze angefangen
hat mögen sie sich erinnern was hat dann
auf den einstieg verursacht der einstieg
war oder die motivation für den anstieg
war die suche ich hatte das gefühl noch
eine eine lehre und durch literatur
durch freundeskreis dachte ich damals
mit 14 frauen mit sicher der lkw das
zufügen und wie oft aus diesen weg haben
sie gedacht das ist der richtige weg
lange zeit oder schon bald nicht mehr es
war immer der richtige weg für die paar
stunden anhielt und am nächsten tag dann
im übernächsten tag verblasst und man
vergisst das ist verblasst und man denkt
dann okay beim nächsten bei der nächsten
erfahrung dann stellt sich die weisheit
oder die der führung ein
und das stimmt zum teil für die zeit des
rausches
irgendwo habe ich gelesen dass sie
gesagt haben mein größter rausch war es
nüchtern zu werden
hier muss ich diesen satz verstehen ich
habe 15 jahre lang meine wahrnehmung und
meine denkprozesse mit substanzen
beeinflusst und zwar 15 jahre ohne einen
tag nüchtern und das aufwachen aus
diesem raus oder dass diese betreuung
zum großen teil war für mich ein
elementares erlebnis also heute dass es
jetzt doch schon 16 jahre her noch heute
ist jeder morgen bin ich auf regen
nämlich gerüchte so wahrnehmen wie sie
sind und nicht so sehr wie es ist oder
wie es mein körper wahrnehmen kann
etwas wofür ich dankbar bin dass wir
viel viel spaß macht und mich mit
befriedigung für herscheid
sie sind arzt und wie schon gesagt habe
sie erforschen die wirkung von
psychedelischen substanzen sind auch ein
stückweit begeistert von den
möglichkeiten dieser neuen substanzen in
der psychiatrie
wenn sie jetzt als arzt diese geschichte
hören müssen sie dann nicht in erster
linie sagen hände weg von jeglichen
rauschmitteln
ja das stimmt natürlich betroffen das
ist eine geschichte die ich aufhöre
als psychiater und ich würde sagen ein
rauschmittel ist nicht per se gut oder
schlecht sondern es kommt immer auf den
kontext an auf die absicht an mit der es
angenommen wird
gerade in der medizin sind ja viele
medikamente für uns sehr wertvoll
beispielsweise opiate zur
schmerzbehandlung oder benzodiazepine
zum beruhigen in der psychiatrie die
wären eigentlich gar nicht mehr
wegzudenken
trotzdem werden sie in anderen kontexten
als rauschmittel missbraucht
ich glaube dass psychedelic falls wir
wirklichen wissenschaftlichen
wirkungsnachweis erbringen könnten in
zukunft wieder den status von
medikamenten bekommen könnten also
wieder so wie im einspieler vorhin wie
das herr hoffmann damals eigentlich
gedacht hatte nicht die vision von
albert hofmann sofern es uns gelingt
tatsächlich auch zu zeigen dass sie
effekte haben im rahmen einer
psychotherapie und vergleichbar oder
vielleicht auch besser wirken als
bisherige medikamente die wir in der
psychiatrie haben
es ist mir kurz den begriff klären
psychedelic kann vielleicht können sie
kurz sagen was zeit zu dieser klasse
psychedelia sind substanzen die das
bewusstsein verändern erweitern da
gehört klassischerweise älteste dazu y
der wirkstoff der magic mushrooms aber
auch meskalin für die zauber kind haben
pilze genau das wären so typische
vertreter des substanzklassen die auch
jetzt in der forschung wieder intensiver
untersucht werden kann die von
versöhnlich verschiedenen substanzen
geredet von unterschiedlichen wirkungen
von unterschiedlichen
einsatzmöglichkeiten
können sie beschreiben wie fühlt sich
ein heroin rausch an jetzt im vergleich
zu sagen die zauber pilzen die man
einnimmt
sie haben ja das meiste ausprobiert das
sind das in welten die psyche haben es
karin oder lsd die substanz macht auch
nicht so ein wahnsinniger unterschied
verändert wirklich auch die wahrnehmung
also die die sinnliche wahrnehmung
tastsinn geruch sind die optischen
eindrücke und kombiniert das mit einem
sehr intensiven empfinden auch sehr
anstrengend also es ist es kann im
besten falle sehr bereichernd sein in
der erfahrung man sieht sachen man sieht
vielleicht auch zusammenhänge ob die
dann da sind wird man wieder aufmacht
oder nicht ist was anderes aber es kann
sehr befriedigend sein und bei den
opiaten
das ist erinnert immer diesen großen
schweren namen und man hat wenn man das
gefühl von diesem großen erlebnis und
das gefährliche am heroin rasch ist dass
er nicht spektakulär ist es ist nicht so
dass etwas wahnsinnig großes nach innen
kommt sondern es ist so dass jeglicher
schmerz verschwindet und die absenz von
jeglichem schmerz ist eben nicht
spektakulär von unheimlich tröstet hat
ja auch damit zu tun dass sozusagen eine
heroin einnahme dann oft eben reagiert
auf eine sucht die sich bereits
entwickelt hat währenddessen ein lsd
trip nicht unbedingt vorher eine sucht
vorliegen muss wenn ich vielleicht noch
einmal bei diesem punkt bleiben sie auch
psychiater sie führen entsprechende
studien durch was genau machen sie haben
mir im vorfeld gesagt viele studierende
melden sich bei ihm viele waren bei den
versuchen mitmachen was genau erlebt man
denn wenn man sich bei ihnen meldet und
bei so einer studie mit machen also
grundsätzlich geht es uns darum die
wirkmechanismen dieser substanzen besser
zu untersuchen das heißt wir untersuchen
frauen gesunde versuchsperson
beispielsweise mit magnetresonanz
tomographie nachdem sie nimmt sich
aktive substanz zu sich genommen haben
wir interessieren uns wie das denken
verändert wird die wahrnehmung aber auch
emotionale prozesse weil wir uns dadurch
laufend besser zu verstehen wie diese
substanzen auch beispielsweise in einer
psychotherapie eingesetzt werden können
und da bestimmte gehirnveränderungen
bringen können die patienten dazu führen
dass sie besser lernen oder fortschritte
machen können im rahmen einer
psychotherapie oder bestimmte defizite
beispielsweise auszugleichen im
emotionalen oder im sozialen bereich
man hört manchmal dass ein lsd-trip ein
begleiteter eines den trip unter
umständen zehn jahre psychotherapie
ersparen können
es ist natürlich eine sehr plakative
bemerkung das würde ich sehr stark
infrage stellen
zwischen kaserne unter drogen sie können
sich das so vorstellen wenn sie zum
dentalhygienikerin dann sieht das gebiss
am nächsten tag auch blitzblank aus aber
wenn sie nicht zähne putzen dann
verblasster effekt relativ schnell
wieder und bei den psychedelic ist das
genauso
ich sehe darin wert vor allem in der
einbettung in eine psychotherapie das
heißt patienten sollten lernen wirklich
nett bewusstseins kompetenz aufzubauen
um die effekte von psycho telegraph
nachhaltig im leben stabilisieren sollen
wie sehen sie das drogen statt
psychotherapie also diese idee der trieb
sozusagen der mir alles bewusst macht
mir alles auf dem tablett serviert dass
ich immer schon wissen wollte aber nicht
selbst meine geschichte ich denke es ist
wirklich eine frage der persönlichkeit
ich denke dieses schnelle diese diese
schnelle selbsterkenntnis die wird sich
nicht einstellen
es gibt wie keine abkürzung für die
arbeit am eigenen ich es gibt keine
es gibt keinen schnellen oder leichten
weg ich kann mir aber durchaus
vorstellen dass es in schwierigen
situationen oder auch im verfahren in
einem verfahren oder sagten ich als
öffner dienen kann
und da bin ich bei meinen mit ghost
eingebettet in eine therapie begleitet
kann man in dieser richtung arbeiten
es ist auch ein bisschen einbrecher
heißen oder stemmeisen für die situation
wo man anders nicht weiterkommt es ist
mir beide sehr vorsichtig das ist
wahrscheinlich dem thema auch angebracht
es gibt viele beispiele in denen trips
in horrortrips geändert haben die haben
mein spieler schon gesehen
es kam so zu suizidversuchen es gibt
psychosen die ausgelöst werden können
durch entsprechende substanzen
trotzdem würde ich gerne micro polen
noch erwähnen ein journalist der dieses
buch geschrieben hat verändere dein
bewusstsein sorgt gerade rund um den
erdball für furore ist im januar auf
deutsch erschienen
und erst die psychiatrie ließe sich
komplett verändern wenn wir beginnen
würden psychedelische substanzen gezielt
einzusetzen
schon ein bisschen ihre position oder
herr schaidinger ich denke es könnte
schon gewissermaßen zu einem
paradigmenwechsel beitragen weil die
bisherigen psychopharmaka die wir haben
was ihren immer noch auf wirkmechanismen
aus den 50er 60er jahren und dienen vor
allem dazu symptome zu substituieren das
heißt eine depression beispielsweise mit
antidepressiva zu behandeln die stimmung
zu heben indem chronisch jeden tag das
serotonin im gehirn angeregt wird
während die psychedelic eigentlich nur
wenige male verabreicht werden und er
seine form von transformations-
passierte therapie sind das heißt im
idealfall lernt die person etwas neues
dazu sich neu im bewusstsein
auszurichten und ist dann nicht
angewiesen täglich zum beispiel
medikamente ein
also keine abkürzung aber es sind kleine
turbo booster dazwischen könnte man so
sagen
sieben herzlichen dank für diese erste
einschätzung rausch erlebnisse gibt es
auch ohne substanzen zwar draußen in der
natur zb im extremsport ja bei mir
sitzen jetzt zwei extremsportler zum
einen ist das mich ja schwer ist
fallschirmspringer und wingsuit
basejumper stürzt sich über 100 mal pro
jahr im freien fall in die tiefe und
daneben sitzt evelyne binsack sie hat
die enden der welt bereist könnte man
sagen den nord- und den südpol oft
monatelang alleine unterwegs in
widrigsten umständen ist aber ganz hoch
hinaus gegangen nämlich aus dann auf den
mount everest wenn sie da an die enden
der welt gehen frei bin sagt versuchen
sie da genau diese frage stelle ich mir
oft auch wenn es stürmt und card ist und
und die witterungsverhältnisse so
schlecht sind dass man wirklich leid tut
da fragt man sich was tue ich eigentlich
hier
aber ich glaube es ist weniger dieses
suchen sondern vielleicht viele mädels
entdecken und bevor ich mich überhaupt
auf so eine reise mache habe ich habe
vier jahre mich vorbereitet bin von
kleineren aufgaben zu größeren
vorangeschritten und und mache mich dann
auf den weg
erleben sie da auch so etwas wie
rauschzustände wenn sie da so tagelang
alleine unterwegs sind nur mit sich
selbst also dass beispielsweise zum
südpol unterwegs sein wo man über 50
tage
bei minus 40 grad celsius weiß hinweis
weil es mit blauem himmel aber das ist
eigentlich
es gibt keine stimulanz für die augen
und es gibt nichts wo man sich ablenken
kann sondern diese zehn stunden am tag
laufen laufen laufen
da kommt man schon in einen run den
bewusstseinszustand aber das merkt man
eigentlich gar nicht so genau das merkt
man vielleicht erst wenn man wieder zu
hause ist aber womit ich angefangen habe
zu spielen war
man hat hier sehr viele schmerzen
schmerzen an den schultern schmerzen an
der hüfte weil man diesen 100 kilogramm
schlitten sieht und dauernd in der
gleichen belastung ist und dann habe ich
angefangen gebete zu zitieren und
rezitieren immer wieder und so konnte
ich zum teil meine schmerzen wie
wegdenken das ist manchmal gelungen
manchmal weniger
und auch die zeit hat sich damit weil
ich nicht damit beschäftigt war dann ist
eine stunde in 15 minuten vorbei dass
ich wieder ein paar nichts helfen kann
einen schluck heißen tee trinken kann
eine kurze pause gönnen kann und so hat
sich dann auch die zeit verkürzt aber
wie gesagt das gelingt einem ab und zu
und dann gelingt weiß einem überhaupt
nicht es ist die konzentration die es
ausmachen aber so einen orten mantra
oder einen meditativen zustand haben sie
vielleicht auch bereich könnte man sagen
ja absolut also das habe ich auch erst
als das erste mal erfahren dass
schmerzen dass ich mit den schmerzen weg
denken konnte also weg mahnt rasieren
konnte oder das eben die zeit ganz
anders wahrgenommen wird wenn man mit
den gedanken in diesem
abgelenkt ist und nicht in der kälte
drinnen ist und nicht im schmerz drin
ist und nicht in der distanz die ja
jeden tag genau gleich aussieht ob man
am ersten tag fast letzten tag totale
reizarmut dass man längst alle das
gleiche genau wann geht eigentlich
wirklich in diese reihe sagen uns hinein
um und das ganze eine andere dimension
zu erfahren
es wäre wenn man drogen nimmt sagt man
oft man hebt ab man fliegt aber sie
fliegen ja wirklich und zwar seit 2003
haben sie über 1000 fallschirmsprünge
gemacht und über 1000 base jumps also wo
sie von felsen gesprungen sind auch mit
so einem wind mit einem flügelanzug
macht auch süchtig das fliegen
also ich weiß nicht ob es mehr wichtig
macht es zum beispiel für einen
leidenschaftlichen segel zu klettern
segeln oder der golf spielt das
golfspielen
ich glaube einfach es ist ein bisschen
extrem man man hat einen höheren gewinn
aber es ist man sollte auch einen einen
höheren preis als auf einem anderen
niveau aber ich glaube ich dass es mehr
richtig gemacht aber es ist auf jeden
fall intensiv als sie haben gesagt
extremer damit wir uns das mal
vorstellen können wie das aussieht nicht
wer sich den berg runter fliegen
[Musik]
freudenschrei bei der landung wie fühlt
sich das an wenn man da unten ist also
ich denke im ganzen sprung ist das so
dass braucht ein licht das man erlebt
weil dann ist die ganze anspannung und
einer landung bei der landung nach dem
dass der schulhof ist die ganze
anspannung weg die ganze konzentration
ist weg und man lässt los genau und eben
das ist unser oben also für mich ist das
so ich hab dann nicht richtige
glücksgefühle ich stehe an einem ganzen
gesicht und bringen das drinks nicht
mehr weg was ist das für eine art von
glück ist das nur endorphin raus oder
ist da was anderes nach was also es ist
sicher auch endorphin ob es ist halt das
ein sprung das ist der lauf man zuerst
mal drei vier stunden dann muss man sich
mental auf den sprung vorbereiten
der sprung beim sprung sailer ist man
extrem konzentriert und eigentlich voll
im moment haben sie auch dieses zeit die
das andere zeit empfinden dass apple im
winter gefüttert hat auf einkauf eine
andere orte im flug eben ist man voll im
jetzt und ich habe da nicht keinen fast
kein zeitgefühl sondern ich bin einfach
im moment und extrem fokussiert auf den
sprung und sie haben wir im vorgespräch
gesagt wenn sie unten sind gelandet sind
sind sie ein besserer mensch weil dann
die ganzen sorgen oder probleme die
täglichen kleinigkeiten über die man
sich sonst aufregt die diesen
bedeutungslos also für mich ist das so
ist das alles bedeutungslos und ich
fühle mich dann frei und entspannt und
fit und voller energie geeignet würden
sie sagen sie sehen das leben nachdem
sie gelandet sind sowie am ansehen
sollte nämlich die unwichtigen dinge
sind wichtig ja ich weiß nicht ob das
gut ist wenn man ihm so durchs leben
gehen würde ob es ist einfach ein moment
wo alles andere wie an bedeutung
verlieren
bei ihnen gibt es da diesen zusagen
gegensätzlich moment war sie auf den
mount everest gestiegen sind als erster
schweizer hin muss man sagen da oben
hört man ja erlebt man so etwas wie
einen höhenrausch ist das so und wenn ja
wie fühlt sich das an
ganz oben zu sein man ist ja nicht mehr
ganz klar im kopf
auch wenn man von 8000 mädchen weg und
sauerstoff geht mit zusätzlichen mann
hat kein zeitgefühl das ist dass selbst
was weggeht und als erstbesteiger ins
bett für den bin ich hab programmiert
dass der gipfel es die hälfte strecke
ist also diejenigen menschen die einfach
für den gibt's zu kämpfen und ihn gibt
so das ziel sehen die sind in höchste
gefahr sondern das ziel ist ja
eigentlich immer die rückkehr die
gesundheit geht
und wenn da gibt es dazugehört und dazu
kommt also dazu gehören würde er aber
wenn er dazu kommt dann ist es umso
besser aber es geht darum gesund zurück
zu gehen und das war ja auch die aufgabe
bei der expedition aber es ist eine
parallele oder das glücksgefühl die
entspannung die einsicht vielleicht
vielleicht auch stellt sich im
nachhinein ein arzt als auch bei ihren
reisen zu unserem südpunkt zum beispiel
jahre absolut und das sind auch ganz
nachhaltige gefühle die gehen als er
vier monate
ja also nach dem mount everest und nach
dem südpol
natürlich kommt dann die die andere
gegen wirkung also auch dieses loslassen
eines eines so lang ersehnten ziel wo
das ist wie eine trennung assistieren
behrenbruch und man hat es erreicht und
da geht man natürlich dann auch auf der
anderen seite wieder eine eine leichte
depression ein aber das gefühl auf dem
gipfel anzukommen ist nicht dasselbe
gefühl wir haben super land zu kommen
nach 414 84 tagen unterwegs sondern ich
weiß ich muss runter aber wer ist war es
so dass nach dem dass ich wieder unten
angekommen war im vorgeschobenen
basislager sind wir nochmals
aufgebrochen nach oben und haben eine
rettungsaktion gestartet von zwei
bergsteigen die darf die raketen mussten
und erst auf diese gesund zurück geholt
hatten nach drei tagen akribischer
arbeit dann kam dieses ist ein großes
glücksgefühl dieses war ich habe es
geschafft und ich erinnere mich aus wird
dann von vom basislager das war auf der
nordseite des selber ist also vom tibet
nach nepal gefahren sind tibetischen
hochland und das sind die wolken sehr
hoch und als ich das erste mal wieder
bäume gesehen habe und die wolken die an
diesen bäumen
ich war den baum ich war aber auch die
wolke und ich war ich selbst und ich
warte gipfel und ich war das
glücksgefühl fast schon ein mystisches
naja das ist wirklich dass das habe ich
die realität ist der beste trip nach dem
mann weg gewesen ist also da erinnere
ich mich schon an dieses gefühl einfach
alles das ein in diesem moment und alles
zu spüren das und diese freude und nicht
einmal stolz sondern einfach diese
freude es geschafft zu haben und mit
diesem erleben ist jetzt wieder nach
hause gehen zu können sie beide gehen ja
nicht nur an die eigenen grenzen sondern
auch an die grenze zum leben selbst oder
zum tod
was für ein verhältnis haben sie zum tod
zum risiko an schwierig also bei mir ist
das das ist so wie die die schattenseite
riskanten natürlich viel viel tolle wenn
ich diese erlebnisse haben könnte ohne
dass ich dort 1 1 ein restrisiko in kauf
nehmen
aber das ist das was ich am anfang
gemeint habe der preis den man
wieso für solche erlebnisse zahlen musst
er ist höher und den nehme ich in kauf
da habe ich noch ganz kurz zu dieser
frage also dass unterwegs sein ist
eigentlich immer mit dem ziel wieder
gesund nach hause zu kommen
und mindestens so lange jetzt meine
mutter gelebt habe habe ich hier auch
das versprochen dass ich nicht eine
dummheit machen also dass ich nie aus
dummheit sterben wird über werte aber
das verhältnis zum tod das tut sich
natürlich schon auf weil man bereits in
jungen jahren in diesem sport im
alpinismus für auch menschen verliert
die man gekannt hat die mit denen man
befreundet gewesen ist und man weiß
natürlich dass ein ein unfall das ein
fehltritt das eine fehlentscheidung dass
ein wetter umbruch dass das fatale
folgen haben kann das haben sie ja auch
erlebt auch viele kollegen kollegen
verloren muss man sagen deswegen
bewundere ihren mut aber auch diese
diese vorsicht und immer wieder an die
grenze zu gehen herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch
schwere verbindung gehen dank lassen
ja und zu uns ist jetzt frau svenja
flaßpöhler gestoßen sie ist philosophien
und chefredaktorin des philosophie
magazins in berlin frau flaßpöhler wenn
sie sich das jetzt angehört haben sie
hätten die wahl zwischen l s dvb pilzen
base jumping oder extrem klettern oder
nüchtern was würden sie wählen
naja nüchtern kenne ich ja und ich bin
würde ich sagen schon ein neugieriger
mensch
deshalb würde ich mich eher für die
anderen optionen entscheiden aber wenn
ich zwischen denen wählen müsste würde
ich wahrscheinlich am ehesten das
klettern nehmen weil mich tatsächlich am
rausch glaube ich also dass ich bin
glaube ich eher der typ der tatsächlich
noch kontrolle behalten will und ich
glaube dass das fand ich jetzt sehr
interessant also der gipfel spielt eine
rolle aber noch wichtiger ist es wieder
nach hause zu kommen und das ist eben
eine beständige beständiges tätig sein
und eine beständige arbeit die es
ermöglicht diesen rausch zu erfahren
aber trotzdem bei sich zu bleiben
wir haben im vorfeld aber auch darüber
gesprochen dass genau das auch die
schwierigkeit ist dass man im rausch
diese ambivalenz habt einerseits wollen
wir dieses total unkontrollierte die
ekstase und ziehen gehen dahin fließen
und andererseits aber bitte dann doch
wieder heil nach hause kommen
ist das nicht ein widerspruch ich glaube
da müsste man jetzt sehr genau denke ich
darüber reden was über was für ein
rausch reden wir eigentlich und ich
glaube der der rausch im engeren sinne
also der rausch der durch alkohol
entsteht durch durch drogen entsteht das
würde ich sagen ist schon ein rausch wo
es eben gerade um den selbstverlust geht
oder die selbst die totale
selbstvergessenheit geht und auch den
kontrollverlust geht in gewisser weise
und das macht es natürlich so gefährlich
und das ist eben auch die nähe des
rausches zum tod und deshalb hat die
kultur ja eben ein sehr ambivalentes
verhältnis zum rausch auf der einen
seite sind wir als kulturwesen als
gesellschafts wesen angehalten bestimmte
grenzen einzuhalten
wir sind leistungs subjekte wir müssen
arbeiten wir können morgens nicht mit
dem kater aufwachen usw und gleichzeitig
stellt uns die kultur aber ja schon auch
möglichkeiten immer schon bereit so ein
bisschen ich habe mal so ein bisschen
triebabfuhr zu leisten
ein bisschen loszulassen grenzen zu
überschreiten und insofern kann man
sagen ist auch eine kulturtechnik finden
sie sich in dieser beschreibung wieder
triebabfuhr und und ihre angebote lsd
trips und ich würde jetzt die arbeit die
wir machen nicht unbedingt in einem
psychoanalytisch framework präsentieren
wir haben heute neue wissenschaftliche
theorien auch biologische theorien wie
wir uns versuchen zu erklären was hier
eigentlich genau passiert habe ich denke
ambivalenz ist ein gutes stichwort
das geht einerseits um eben dieses
gefühl von ozeanische selbst entgrenzung
von flow von abenteuerlust was auch sehr
eng mit unserem dopamin system im gehirn
gekoppelt ist und letztlich auch die
menschliche evolution vorangebracht hat
also wo wären wir heute ohne diesen
antrieb was meinen sie das genau da ist
natürlich viel neugier tränen oder
entdeckerlust ich denke sowohl sportler
wie auch wissenschaftler oder künstler
begeben sich in diese rauschhaften
zustände wo sie dann zu höchstleistungen
letztlich fähig sind und so eigentlichen
beitrag leisten oder auch zur
zivilisation
das ist jetzt ein sehr positives bild
vom rausch der ausstellungs letztlich
dazu treibt extrem leistungen zu
vollbringen vielleicht auch das extreme
zu ersehnen wie geht es ihnen die
zuhören hernani weil es ja immer auch
die gefahr des rausches sozusagen
miterlebt haben also ich würde beides
ich finde das ist sehr diffizil in beide
richtungen also ich persönlich würde das
drama hast
im sinn von gerade wenn man die
kunstlandschaft jeder kunstschüler denkt
die großen künstler haben drogen
genommen haben da ihre größte leistung
erbracht ich muss das auch und da wird
eine kausalität hergestellt die
eigentlichen korrelation ist also viele
künstler hatten auf inhaber nicht jeder
der drogen genommen hat ist ein großer
künstler geworden und bei diesen
gesellschaftlichen aspekt da drogen
würde ich es als schmiermittel also ich
könnte mir keine gesellschaft ohne
rausch vorstellen
doch schon ohne alkohol war für mich
unvorstellbar weil viele leute diesen
teil an ventil oder diesen teil von 1
themen benötigen um in einer sozialen
strukturen wie wir sie heute haben
überhaupt funktionieren zu können
über die gesellschaft wirklich später
gerne noch einmal sprechen
bleiben die vielleicht noch einmal kurz
auch bei der wirkung warum wir diese
substanzen zu uns nehmen waren was
fasziniert eigentlich daran und ein
begriff könnte ja dieses psychedelische
sein also das ist ein griechischer
begriff wenn man den übersetzt heißt das
bewusstseinserweiternd was wird denn da
genau erweitert herrschte kein welche
richtung erweitert also einerseits werde
natürlich wahrnehmungen vertieft
intensiviert gefühle kommen hoch das
denken verläuft nicht mehr in den
gewohnten bahnen bei höheren dosen kann
sein dass ich auch das körpergefühl
beginnt aufzulösen
das auch zeit und raum eigentlich nicht
mehr in der gewohnten art existieren und
die grenzen zwischen ich und umwelt
verschmelzen so dass das individuum
sicherlich als teil eines größeren
ganzen erlebt das kann sehr positiv
erlebt werden aber wenn die person auch
widerstände hat oder ängste hat sich so
gehen zu lassen kann das auch sehr
angstvoll sein und das sind dann oft so
die schlaufen die dann letztlich auch in
einen hohen tritt minden können aus
philosophischer sicht muss das ja
interessant sein für sie weil
grundsätzlich kann man sagen philosophie
hat sich immer interessiert für
erkenntnis immer interessiert dafür mit
dem bewusstsein weiter zu kommen also
suchen sie vielleicht mal eine session
ja ich weiß nicht ich bin ich muss
wirklich sagen ich bin mit bier
sozialisiert also bier kenne ich mit mir
kann ich umgehen
ich habe mir jetzt nicht so
bewusstseinserweiternd oder doch wo das
würde ich so nicht sagen aber ich muss
sagen ich hab' ich habe tatsächlich auch
berührungsängste
also was was eben solche drogen angeht
wahrscheinlich hängt es auch sehr stark
davon ab mit was man sozialisiert wurde
er dass ich einfach nie berührung damit
hatte und jetzt für mich nicht sicher
nicht so richtig klar wird warum soll
ich das jetzt nehmen sie sagen
bewusstseinserweiterung ja das stimmt
gleichzeitig hätte ich aber tatsächlich
immer die sorge dass da etwas mit meinem
geist mit meinem gehirn passiert dass
ich nicht mehr unter kontrolle habe dass
ich nicht mehr beeinflussen kann
bestimmt stecken rät sie aber bestimmt
steckt ja auch so ein bisschen so ein
authentizität stick bei mir drin dass
ich also ich habe zum beispiel schon
große probleme überhaupt eine
kopfschmerztablette zu nehmen weil ich
das gefühl habe okay ich hab jetzt
kopfschmerzen da muss ich jetzt durch
das sind ebenso das ist echt ich habe
kopf werden dann frage ich mich warum
habe ich dir jetzt strengt mich
irgendetwas zu sehr an also schmerzen
sind ja auch eine weise sich selbst zu
erkennen oder bestimmte situationen zu
analysieren vielleicht sein leben zu
ändern deshalb sie haben vorhin schon
die psychoanalyse erwähnt ich bin eben
auch psychoanalyse sozialisiert ich habe
eine psychoanalyse gemacht sehr lange
und ich glaube diese dieser arbeit an
sich selbst die eben auch
bewusstseinserweiterung erweitert sein
kann
total bewusstseinserweiternd aber für
mich gehört die arbeit am selbst
eigentlich immer dazu
weil ihnen erwarten weil ich dabei bin
und vielleicht ist hat das auch was
protestantisches weiß ich nicht ich bin
gar nicht protestantisch aber manchmal
denke ich ich wäre es
also insofern habe ich da wirklich ich
habe da sehen muss den respekt davor
finden sie dann
ich sehe also dass
bewusstseinserweiternde das gab das
gefühl vom 1 1 mit an
ich habe bei mir und bei anderen leuten
die ich kenne die in den psychedelic
unterwegs waren und erlebt dass ein sehr
egozentrische art ist also die
wahrnehmung wird verändert vielleicht
sogar die bewusstseins abläufe werden
verändert hat die realität bleibt sich
gleich also wenn ich mit freunden
unterwegs war auf seelischen drogen war
jeder auf seinem eigenen planet und ich
hatte zwar schon das gefühl ich sei mit
allen anderen verbunden hat aber
effektiv für mich danach nicht mehr
gestanden weil es auch wirklich nicht so
wahr ich war auf meinem eigenen planeten
in meiner eigenen realität und das hat
bei mir am ende immer ein gewisses
gefühl von einsamkeit ausgelöst nachdem
raus ja also ich denke der rausch ist
das eine
und der alltag ist das andere und wie
schaffen wir da quasi eine
querverbindung herzustellen
psychedelische substanzen können
natürlich auch uns in illusionen oder
den falsche wahrheiten treiben was mich
als psychotherapeut interessiert ist
quasi mit jedem patienten oder mit jedem
menschen der so eine erfahrung gemacht
hat letztlich sich zu fragen was aus
dieser erfahrung kannst du mitnehmen und
in dein leben integrieren und ich denke
ohne diese arbeit verblasst das relativ
schnell im universum
ich würde gerne noch einmal auf diese
frage des authentischen zurückkommen auf
das echte weil die ja wahrscheinlich
alle die man gläschen wein getrunken
haben wissen dass in dem moment
vielleicht unglaublich geniale ideen
haben und am tag darauf wenn jeder an
die notizen lesen merken ja
ja so genial was jetzt vielleicht doch
nicht und dann fragt man sich das war
eigentlich echt daran und wir merken wir
haben uns das vielleicht ein bisschen
eingebildet die großartige künstlerische
bewegung die man gerade durchgemacht hat
und in diesem zusammenhang kann man sich
ja wirklich fragen was ist eigentlich
das echte in so einem rauschzustand
und ich glaube man muss im moment über
tc boyles neuesten roman sprechen das
nicht weil er da drin im grunde genommen
timo willi riß geschichte nacherzählt
der harvard professor für psychologie
der der vater der gugl bewegung war und
mit lsd ganz viel experimentiert hat und
er sagt das ist wirklich eine
neuprogrammierung des gehirns und es
geht letztendlich darum wirklich das
gehirn so zu strukturieren dass wir ganz
neu zu sehen lernen
aber was sehen wir denn da ist das
einbildung oder realität
oder ist die frage schon falsch und
demaskiert nicht als eine person die
keine ahnung hat sie lachen so nett
verteidiger für mich als förster sind
diese substanz natürlich faszinierende
tools oder um einblicke zu gewinnen wie
unser gehirn eigentliche realität
hervorbringt wir können ziemlich alle
dimensionen unseres realität sehens in
verschiedene himmelsrichtungen erweitern
und studieren was da nicht passiert und
ich glaube ich würde nicht sagen die
substanzen implizieren eine absolute
realität oder etwas woran man zu glauben
hat sondern sie können uns vielleicht
etwas darüber lehrern wie realität sind
dann steht quasi in den maschinenraum
des bewusstseins reinzuschauen und die
verschiedenen elemente darin nichts zu
erkennen die
zudem beitragen was letztlich realität
ist vielleicht machen wir noch ein strom
zu diesen sogenannten micro dasing das
kam ganz am anfang im einspieler auch
bereits vor das sind kleinste dosen an
lsd im moment wird sehr viel darüber
diskutiert scheint auch in der schweiz
mehr und mehr verbreitet zu sein
vor allem im silicon valley ein enormer
trends das heißt menschen nehmen
kleinste dosen von lsd und war nicht
mehr mit dem ziel auf den trip zu gehen
uns irgendwelche
bewusstseinserweiternden geschichten da
er ab zu feiern sondern um in erster
linie produktiver kreativer leistungs
bewusster zu werden
ja das ist eigentlich kann man sagen die
die perversion des genießens also die
umdrehungen weil das genießen eigentlich
wenn man es kulturgeschichtlich
betrachtet ist es eben immer eher an die
grenzüberschreitung gekoppelt also ich
überschreite die grenze des leistungs
imperativ des trieb verzicht also all
das was wir was wir tagtäglich leisten
müssen ohne dass wir so richtig merken
aber als kulturwesen machen wir das
eigentlich minütlich dauernd und das
genießen überschreitet genau diese renz
und daraus resultiert auch die lust also
das kann man wirklich in der
philosophiegeschichte von saab über
georges partei sehr schön nachverfolgen
dass es immer eigentlich diese die lust
an der grenzüberschreitung ist und
daneben die lust gerade nicht produktiv
zu sein also all diese diese
gesetzmäßigkeiten unseres alltags
wirklich auszuhebeln und in dem man
jetzt aber sagt man man nimmt den genuss
in kleinen dosen um die produktivität
anzugucken dass ich meine setzten noch
gar nicht wertend aber es ist erst mal
ganz deskriptiv oder beschreibend gesagt
eine perversion eine umdrehung der logik
sehen sie das auch so aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht wäre ich da
jetzt relativ zurückhaltend was das
micro sim betrifft ich denke wir wissen
noch gar nicht genau was es genau macht
und es
wir haben zwar viele erfahrungsberichte
im internet aber letztlich wissen wir
noch nicht ob das letztlich auf eine
mine bildungs effekt oder einem placebo
effekt beruht weil die person sich
vielleicht suggerieren ihre ressourcen
besser nutzen zu können indem sie
täglich irgend so eine kleine menge
einer substanz zu führen aber rein
pharmakologisch würde ich sagen war es
denkbar dass microsim effekte hat wir
wissen es einfach nur schmunzeln
ja ich kenne leute die gerade unter
großem stress makellosen gemacht haben
in kreativen berufen oder das was man
heute kreativen berufen
das war witzig waren wenn man diese
leute waren jahr oder zwei begleitet hat
in der arbeit hat man gemerkt ihre
arbeit wurde nicht besser nicht
schneller nicht kreativer nicht
überraschend aber sie waren eher
zufrieden damit was ja auch ein schöner
effekt ist wunderbar effekt aber das
habe ich vorher gemacht mit der
egozentrik man verändern nur begrenzt
die äußere realität aber man kann
durchaus die eigene einstellung dazu zu
verändern und über einem jahr oder zwei
konstant dazu kommen dass die eigene
zufriedenheit mit der arbeit dazu führt
dass man dann wirklich jahren kreativer
kreativen zugang zu den sachen krieg das
hat aber ein bisschen mit diesem placebo
effekt zu tun
und das hat natürlich wie bei für beim
kokain die in der in der arbeit damit zu
tun dass man das gefühl hat man tut
etwas um die kontrolle zu behalten und
in unserer arbeitswelt ist eine substanz
nehmen oder den leuten man kann den
leuten wahrscheinlich auch hustensaft
geben und sagen das gibt dir die
kontrolle über den deine kreativität
kann schon hilfsmittel sein und dann
über zeit wirklich kreativer zu sein
aber ich glaube der punkt auf den führer
hinaus wollte den würde ich doch gerne
auch mal aufnehmen der ist ja schon
wichtig zu sehen wenn man dieses buch
von drei liest dann begegnet man einer
hippie welt die leute sind splitternackt
nehmen lsd und rennen durchs gras und
fühlen sich die tiere oder käfer oder
was weiß ich alles
dessen heute mehr die idee ist
vielleicht man nimmt sowohl dosiert
kleine dosen um ein bisschen kreativ zu
sein am computer oder man geht auf den
begleiteten trip macht das ein mal im
jahr und therapeutischen nutzen zu haben
ich über spitze jetzt extra von diesen
aber wo bleibt eigentlich der
dionysischen rausch den nietzsche noch
besungen hat gibt es dennoch
das hat sich geändert seit den 90ern
heute arbeitet man fünf tage und passt
sich im system ein und leistet und
freitagabends geht's los das kann dann
pillen seien das kann alkohol sein dann
kann man loslassen und sich quasi
erholen um dann montags wieder dort sein
insofern ist es micro singh eine andere
form von diesem wochenende lief das
heißt ich habe um jeden tag ein bisschen
was anstatt jedes wochenende den
totalabsturz den totalabsturz
ja ich finde sie beschreiben noch eine
arbeitswelt die glaube ich so gar nicht
mehr existiert also etwas was ich immer
mehr erlebe es eigentlich die
entgrenzung der arbeitswelt also auch
ins wochenende hinein also gerade
natürlich durch die die durch die
digitalisierung also betreffen wir
tragen ja alle unsere produktionsmittel
quasi in der tasche unserer
arbeitsmittel und was ich tatsächlich er
sagen würde ist dass die arbeit zum
rausch wird und zum genuss wird und
zurück zum mac zum exzess sogar also es
gibt ja die arbeitssucht workaholic und
dass der genuss umgekehrt eigentlich
immer mehr zur arbeit wird also dass man
den leuten fast sagen muss jetzt genießt
doch mal jetzt entspannt euch doch mal
und das gebe ich glaube dass es die
problematik ist die immer mehr leute
haben gar nicht so sehr dass sie
irgendwie abhängig sind oder den
rausgehen das gibt es natürlich auch
aber ich kenne viele leute und dazu
würde ich mich sogar auch wahrscheinlich
sogar erzählen also die leute die eher
probleme haben mal loszulassen
wir sind mitten im thema wir können uns
einen kleinen eine kleine pause mit raus
und zwar mit einem wort raus mit dem
schriftsteller pedro lenz
das ist mein job meine thomas rupp was
war
der mann entriss und büros stehen war
gerufen um gelder in europa wieder
rechtzeitig kollegen wirklich um die oma
look studium kapitalaufbau das was die
autos machen dass die möglichkeit das
macht die menschen morgen die chefs
bankkonto die spielgruppe the machine 18
was los ist wenn ich das aber schon
wieder nach hause reisen zwischen dem
was los ist und dann das konzil der
penis heimischen standort für das machen
und sie auch für das womöglich schwer
getroffen hatte machte es aber gut
bislang ist es für andere des ortes im
medienrecht projekt über 1000 über das
flugzeug für mini empfindungen das
putzmittel für mini keyboard europa für
medien den abgründen über die am
liebsten ständiger sorge ständiger bis
nach ständiger bis sie war für ips nütze
initiiert normalität wieder neue jetzt
verstanden worden
dubai dpa direkt ob es mitmacht
er passierte bis ich überhaupt früchte
bis dem mikro protest aus wo die innere
vorstellung des fleisches fauser mofas
der mensch erschossen kilometer von
reykjavik erkenntnissen aus ihren
kellern besprüht natürlich mehr gas oder
also dass vw die in der nähe hamburgs
schwerte epd medien außer ist erwachse
branche zu finden
ich spüre der vor allem das hohe gut mal
verlieh die probefahrt ich spürte die
geborgenheit dominic west city navarino
wolle die bittere realität ist
alltägliche realität ist als marke
pfarrkirche realität isches glas wasser
realität heute paul qualität welche
realität ist für die jeweils eine keine
vorstellung was ist zwischen bis
optimieren dies verbessere wenn da also
näher
immer besser machen ist gerade so gut
war gut sie
ja bei mir sitzen jetzt zwei
ausgewiesene sucht und drogen experten
zum alten ist dass boris quednau er ist
der psychologe und professor an der
psychiatrischen universitätsklinik
zürich und erforscht die wirkung
unterschiedlicher drogen auf geist und
körper und daneben toni pertl psychiater
und präsident der eidgenössischen
kommission für suchtfragen berät also
den bundesrat
wenn es um politik geht herzlich
willkommen in beiden herbert
ich möchte mit ihnen beiden gleich über
unseren umgang sprechen aus
gesellschafts den wir haben sollten mit
drogen und rauschmittel davor aber
interessiert mich was sie zur diskussion
auf dem sofa denken
zu diesen trend drogen
leistungssteigernde substanzen micro-sim
wurde erwähnt daneben gibt es aber auch
dieses mdma das uns irgendwie empathisch
mach das partydroge und endlich
verbindung zu anderen menschen heraus
aus dieser einsamkeit dann gibt es
dieses alaska dass die leute in den
amazonas reißen und den zu deiner wurzel
trinken und dann irgendwie sich mit der
natur wieder in verbindung für was sagt
das alles über unsere zeit erwartet
wir haben vorher gehört dass der konsum
vom sicher tiefen zum start sind auch
eine kulturelle praxis ist und
kulturelle praxis verändern sich in der
heutigen zeit konsumiert und dann
versiegelt wo sie hierzu hält haben und
alle zeit haben wir hier natürlich dafür
substanz und konsumieren die mehr
leistung bringen und auf der anderen
seite haben wir aber substanzen die uns
rasch entspannen lassen die unsere stadt
in die freizeit so quasi entlassen und
ihn danach wieder ein drittes element
das wir substanzen konsumieren in marco
russ ist im norden und marketingbereich
wo es eigentlich darum geht dass wir
etwas nehmen aber auch nicht zu viel
nehmen also wir sind hier so in der zeit
wo es wo wir also ein bisschen kaffee
kaffee für ihn und seine ohne rahm ohne
sahne und unsere lektion gelernt hat als
wir hier in dieser beratung und da haben
wir eine multi einer gesellschaft mit
sehr vielen unterschiedlichen aspekten
die in kurzer zeit erfüllt werden müssen
da helfen diese droge natürlich diese
befindlichkeiten die wir suchen schnedl
und rasch und häufig auch zielführend
die philosophin svenja flaßpöhler hat
von einer perversion des genießens
gesprochen
ja ich glaube jede gesellschaft trichter
verdient die drogen die sie bekommt und
das problem ist glaube ich dass wir
immer das gefühl haben raus wäre etwas
universelles dass es immer schon gegeben
hat und wir nicht wirklich unterscheiden
zwischen re kreativen rausch also genuss
rausch und dem rausch der in spirituelle
erfahrungen eingebettet ist es gibt
kultur vergleichende studien aus den
70ern die später tatsächlich nicht
weiter wiederholt wurden die gezeigt
haben ja stimmt bewusstseinserweiternde
oder bewusstseinsverändernde erfahrung
gehören immer schon in unserer kultur
kultur historie viele völker viele
gesellschaften haben das betrieben aber
die allermeisten haben das immer im
rahmen spirituelle erfahrungen betrieben
und wenn man sich anschaut wie der
genuss rausch gesehen wurde dann ist das
in meisten religionen eine sünde gewesen
und deshalb glaube ich unser verhältnis
zur sucht- oder zum unser verhältnis zum
rausch hat sich insofern verändert als
dass wir bestimmte werte korrektive
nicht mehr besitzen also religiöse werte
korrektive die dazu geführt haben dass
wir wahrscheinlich in der berauschten
zeit die wir je hatten leben ja also ich
glaube aus mittel sind heute viel weiter
verbreitet als je zuvor in der
menschheitsgeschichte
auch wenn immer das behauptet wird dass
rausch immer schon teil der menschheit
war aber ich glaube kulturhistorisch ist
das fast nicht haltbares gruppe keine
keine keine studien die zeigen dass der
der bewusstseinserweiternde genuss
rausch weit verbreitet war das ist das
ist in meinen augen gemüter zweck ist
ein anderer ist ein spiritueller mehr
sondern irgendwie man möchte
runterfahren
oder genau genießt sie eher werte sagen
wir als gesellschaft heute müssen
radikal umdenken und an anderen umgang
finden mit drogen im allgemeinen und die
konkreten was das cannabis angeht das
kiffen plädieren sie für eine
legalisierung oder für eine regulierung
was für eine aufhebung des verbots warum
dann können sie das kurze also erst
einmal wird in der schweiz in europa in
der halben welt wird cannabis konsumiert
auch dort wo es verboten ist
zweitens haben wir eine deutliche
zunahme der der thc konzentration also
der wirkstoff kurzmann haben unendlich
hohe oder 54 prozent der wahl geht das
cbt runter und das haben wir weil die
substanz verboten ist weil man den ic
viel geld verdienen kann und unsere
antwort der burg altena kommission
versucht worden wir haben gerade diese
woche eine neue papiere publiziert zu
diesen fragen uns geht es darum dass wir
einerseits akzeptieren das psychoaktive
substanzen oder cannabis im speziellen
konsumiert wird und dass wir eine
antwort finden müssen wie können wir
konstruktiv damit umgehen und
konstruktiv heißt in diesem falle wie
können wir sicherstellen dass sie die
substanzen sauber angebaut werden dass
die sauber sehen dass die idee thc
konzentration einen minimalen der
maximalen wert nicht übersteigt das die
verarbeitung der substanz gut geht dass
wir auch orte haben wo die sie verkaufen
können und ganz zentral dass wir
jugendliche und kinder schützen können
vor diesem konstrukt heute können wir
das nicht heute haben wir einen
wildwuchs dh wir haben kollateralschäden
dieses gesetzes und dieses gesetz
erfüllt seinen zweck nicht genau das
sagen sondern man muss das verbot
aufheben um es kontrollieren zu können
und events ionen und um regulieren zu
können und prävention
zu können sich wenn jemand der die
gefahren wissenschaftlich erforscht
verschiedene drogen und rauschmittel
auch von von cannabis was sind denn die
größten gefahren beim kiffen
also da muss man zwei dinge sehr stark
auseinander halten und das jetzt alles
dazu legen wir den rahmen der dennoch
wirklich sprengen aber ganz kurz wir wir
wissen dass cannabis chronisch
konsumiert bei erwachsenen etwas anders
macht als bei jugendlichen
und tatsächlich hat sich in den letzten
20 jahren gezeigt dass wenn ein
kontrollierter cannabiskonsum bei
erwachsenen da ist das ass oder die die
anzahl der spätfolgen relativ gering ist
so bald wieder eine abstinenz erreicht
wird und cannabis gehört jetzt nicht zu
den suchtmitteln mit den höchsten
suchtpotenzial das heißt also die gefahr
ist moderat von cannabis abhängig zu
werden
dann habe ich tatsächlich relativ wenig
spätfolgen anders sieht es bei den
beiden jugendlichen haus da gibt es
wirklich sehr überzeugende daten dass
wenn ich während der hirnentwicklung
cannabis konsumieren
im späteren leben bestimmte prozesse
offensichtlich nicht mehr oder gleicher
weise stattfinden das ist zum beispiel
zur intellektuellen einschränkungen
kommt das ist vielleicht so was wie
temperaments veränderungen kommen sogar
reduktion des antriebs da ist und so
weiter
der jugendschutz wenn ich das ganze wäre
es ganz zentral und der muss irgendwie
garantiert werden sie haben das
suchtpotenzial angesprochen das
vergleichsweise gering ist bei bei
nikotin zum beispiel viel viel höher ist
und wir haben eine grafik vorbereitet
die wir uns kurz anschauen
die die verbreitung und das
suchtpotenzial unterschiedlichen
rauschmittel darstellt das scheint so zu
sein
[Musik]
alkohol ist überall präsent 93 prozent
der schweizerinnen und schweizer über 15
haben schon alkohol konsumiert 27
prozent von diesen werden abhängig 85
prozent trinken mehr oder weniger
regelmäßig von den illegalen substanzen
ist cannabis am stärksten verbreitete
sei es als gras haschisch oder öl
jeder dritte schweizer hat schon mal
gekifft 9 prozent von ihnen werden
abhängig kokain geschnupft oder geraucht
haben vier prozent der bevölkerung schon
einmal probiert von diesen werden 17
prozent süchtig was das suchtpotenzial
betrifft steht an oberster stelle
nikotin gefolgt vom opium derivat heroin
1 prozent von herrn und frau schweizer
haben schon einmal heroin konsumiert
ganze 23 prozent der erstkonsumenten
werden süchtig
[Musik]
die partydroge ecstasy haben vier
prozent schon ausprobiert die chance
davon abhängig zu werden ist sehr klein
lsd die stark alu cino gene substanz
haben drei prozent mindestens einmal
konsumiert von diesen entwickeln 5
prozent eine psychische aber keine
körperliche abhängigkeit
ja es gibt natürlich neben den drogen
die der drogensucht ein andere süchte
wie zum beispiel spielsucht und es
widmet sich am 9 mai mit einem
themenabend dem thema sucht es gibt zwei
doch filme und eine sendung einstein
dazu das sollten sie nicht verpassen
jetzt bei ihnen beiden sie haben ja sehr
unterschiedliche haltung zum umgang mit
drogen gesellschaftlich sie kennen aber
dieselben studien dieselben fakten warum
ist denn das so haben sie ein anderes
menschenbild oder ein anderes
verständnis davon was der staat leisten
soll und wo die eigenverantwortung des
einzelnen aufhört herr trennung ja
wahrscheinlich spielt es eine große
rolle
ich bin tatsächlich echter protestanten
ist er würde den wahlprotesten gewesen
und das hat sicherlich etwas der haltung
zum menschen und zur zur aufgabe des
staates zu tun als wenn man ein eher
paternalistisches bild des staates hat
dann hat man wahrscheinlich auch er die
repressive drogenpolitik im auge
also dass vater staat uns vor uns selbst
schützt genau also beziehungsweise wer
nicht das gefühl habe alles selbst
verantwortung ich aber auch um die
psychologischen schwächen des menschen
weiß nicht dass selbst verantwortung
durchaus lücken haben kann und dass
nicht jeder in gleicher weise in der
lage ist selbst verantwortung zu üben
dass dann der staat dazu sagen da
einspringen muss und die leute die das
nicht so gut können auch vor sich selbst
schützen muss
herbert empfehlen sie den bundesrat
verantwortungslose maßnahmen den
einstigen rangehen also ich bin
überzeugt und sagt das immer klaren
deutlich erwachsene menschen brauchen
kann
eine lebensführung besser ist das heißt
erwachsene menschen brauchen wieder
psychologen sozialarbeiter sich japan
noch ärzte die ihnen sagen was sie
konsumieren dürfen weshalb war mit wem
sie sex haben dürfen im bett und dürfen
auf den mount everest also denn die
tiefe spielen
das heißt diese verantwortung diese
freiheit bedeutet braucht verantwortung
und verantwortung in diesem fall heißt
das wir natürlich wissen was wir tun
dass wir als starker staat muss hier nur
die sicherheit zu verpflanzen so sicher
zur verfügung stellen dass der mensch
selber entscheiden kann was er damit
machen kann es gibt dann immer noch mit
das ist klar
die mit diesen tipps tat nicht umgehen
können und da sind wir ein solidarischer
start
da müssen wir die hilfe anbieten damit
diese menschen wieder auf die beine
kommen aber grundsätzlich sind wir
menschen fähig mit psychoaktiven
substanzen umzugehen weil wir lernen
können damit umzugehen
das heißt wir müssen als gesellschaft
den rausch kultivieren aber auch
kontrollieren ein stück weit aber nicht
durch verbote und sie wünschen sich eine
nüchterne gesellschaft naja ich wünsche
mir zunächst einmal auch eine
aufgeklärte gesellschaft und wir beide
sind ja einer meinung wenn es zb um die
kriminalisierung des konsums geht oder
ob beziehungsweise die
entkriminalisierung des konsums die wir
beide für sehr nötig halten aber ich
glaube das problem ist ein anderes
nämlich dass rausch eben nicht nur eine
individuelle erfahrung ist sondern dass
raus schnell auch andere personen
betreffen kann und da glaube ich raus
endet sozusagen die freiheit des eigenen
rausches endet auch immer an der
freiheit anderer personen dann
eingeschränkt werden werden der begriff
der familienvater abends zu hause sitzt
und sich an der hausarbeit nicht mehr
beteiligt dann betrifft es eben die
ehefrau oder die kinder und so weiter
und ich glaube eben dass wir viel zu
sehr von seinem der individualistischen
von so einer individualistischen
sichtweise auf den rausch inzwischen
geprägt sind und immer wieder ausblenden
das bedeutet wenn einzelne personen sich
herausnehmen sporadisch oder vor allen
dingen regelmäßig berauscht zu sein was
das für ihr soziales umfeld bedeutet
aber bei ihrer position ist für mich
natürlich unklar wo zieht man die
grenzen also meine kokain kennt man dass
es sie kennen die die gefahren soll man
das auch legalisieren kontrollieren
regulieren und keine ahnung bis zum
heroin wo ziehen sie die grenze
warum also ich finde wir müssen etwas
sehen wir haben einen konsum heute in
unserer gesellschaft und diese konsum
ist unkontrolliert die frage stellt sich
wie können wir diese probleme bessere in
den griff bekommen und die frage ist
kann man das besser über verbote oder
kann man das besser über regulierungs
modellen ich finde natürlich auch wenn
sie nur mal cannabis beginnen weil da
aus die substanz ist im heißen
konsumiert wie bei den anderen bin ich
auch sehr sehr vorsichtig und würde auch
ein nur als ihr sorgfältig aufgebaute
forschung unterstützen frage wieviel
rausch unsere gesellschaft eigentlich
verträgt werden jetzt gleich noch weiter
diskutieren auf dem sofa und sie herr
werden da noch platz nehmen zunächst
aber vielen herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch
ich kann der gesellschaft ist das ein
graus oder eine schöne wunschvorstellung
wir haben vorhin schon so ein bisschen
ein disput darüber
sie haben schon gesagt das wäre für sie
auch nicht das ziel gleichzeitig sind
sie eine person die die abgründe der
rauschzustände auch kennengelernt hat ja
ich denke eine eine rauschfrei
gesellschaft ist nicht anzustreben
es würde von menschen bild ausgehen dass
absolut an der realität wie man sie hat
erlebt wie man sie sieht vorbei geht und
das würde zu zwängen führen das würde
war für mich eine keine wirklich gute
vorstellung
jetzt bei den verboten hat man ja schon
gewisse erfahrung gemacht in den usa in
der position in den 90ern in zürich mit
der sehr streng dem sehr strengen verbot
von heroin das überhaupt nichts genutzt
hat
man muss raus wirklich wie ein trieb
verstehen das ist nicht etwas dass das
einfach verschwinden wird weil es wird
weil wir es nicht gut finden
ich habe die diskussion zwischen der
individuellen und der gesellschaft ebene
sehr spannend gefunden weil da sich die
frage stellt wie raus braucht eine
gesellschaft also wie oft muss ich meine
verantwortung abgeben können loslassen
können entspannen können um den rest der
zeit quasi diese verantwortung tragen zu
können
und für mich war daraus nicht immer aber
oft der punkt an dem ich entspannen oder
loslassen konnte damit ich danach wieder
bereit war meine leistung zu erbringen
mit der zeit hoffentlich verwahrt ist
für die entspannung und für die leistung
meine meine substanzen
aber grundsätzlich denke ich wenn die
möglichkeit zum schnellen entspannen
oder zum schnellen genießen weggenommen
wird und man für alles drei wochen
ferien machen muss
die gleiche entspannung zu erreichen wie
man nach ein paar gläsern wein und einem
guten gespräch
das wäre nicht für mich nicht
anzustreben
ich glaube wir sehen die ganze zeit
schon die unterschiedliche zwecke einen
rauschzustand verfolgen kann also die
entspannung dazwischen aber auch das
totale aus sich heraus brechen die
ekstase die bewusstseinserweiterung so
viele substanzen so viele
unterschiedliche ziele
mich würde aber trotzdem noch
interessieren die wir eigentlich auf die
realität blicken pedro lenz hat vorhin
das schöne bild gebracht die realität
ist so fade wie ein magerquark ich es so
schlimm reicht ihren der magerquark ist
eine sehr gute frage
ich empfinde meine meine realität
tatsächlich gar nicht als magerquark
aber und muss ihr oder will er deshalb
auch gar nicht häufig entfliehen
ich habe ein bisschen eher das gefühl
dass wir in zeiten leben die sehr rasant
sich gerade verändern und dass viele
menschen damit auch mit sorgen und angst
reagieren und natürlich dann die
versuchung nahe liegt diese sorgen und
diese angst zu wegzumachen weg zu
rauschen zu sagen reeperbahn zu rauschen
oder davon zu naschen genau und ich habe
dann das gefühl möchte ich eigentlich in
der gesellschaft leben die die wegschaut
die bewusst die ganze zeit wegschaut ich
habe ohnehin das gefühl unsere
elektronischen unterhalter die wir eben
immer bei uns tragen tragen schon stark
dazu bei dass wir sehr viel uns nicht
mehr mit der realität beschäftigen und
wenn das weiter verstärkt wird durch
substanzen dann wären wir uns vielleicht
auch gar nicht mehr dann verändern wir
vielleicht diese welt gar nicht mehr so
wie sie es braucht damit wir weiterhin
ihr leben können so eine dauerhaft schon
ein bisschen aushalten aber auch ein
bisschen um deutschen der vor allem den
schmerz der schmerz ist so was gut und
den schmerz immer weg machen das ist
schlecht
wenn wir müssen was verändern wenn es
wehtut darauf lasse mir geht ganz ganz
viel durch den kopf also erst mal wollte
ich sagen dass ich innerlich herbert
sehr zugestimmt habe weil ich
tatsächlich auch sehr auf die mündigkeit
des menschen setze und glaube dass man
durch gesellschaftliche verbote eher das
gegenteil erreicht also weil ich glaube
dass tatsächlich das verbot und der
exzess sind eigentlich zwei seiten ein
und derselben medaille je mehr ich
verbiete desto größer wird die lust an
der grenzüberschreitung und der exzess
und je mehr ich irgendwie die die die
liste oder die das bedürfnis irgendwie
nach grenzüberschreitung unterdrücke
desto größer wird der ausbruch seien
und dann wollte ich nur mal sagen zum
magerquark ich finde man muss finde ich
schon sehen dass einfach die menschliche
existenz ja eine ist die nicht so
einfach ist
also wir wissen dass wir sterben werden
wir stellen uns die sinnfrage warum sind
wir überhaupt auf der welt
also es ist eigentlich eine eine
existenz sie mit wahnsinnig vielen
fragen und unsicherheiten verbunden ist
und ich finde es dann ehrlich gesagt
okay dass man hin und wieder den rausch
aussucht und ich würde schon sagen dass
das zur menschlichen existenz wirklich
auch dazu gehört genauso wieder also
dieser überschuss genauso wie auch das
bedürfnis nach schönheit nach kunst nach
nach so vielen dingen die wir eigentlich
nicht im wirklichen sinne brauchen um zu
leben was irgendwie hinausgeht über über
wasser und brot aber genau wir brauchen
von trieb war vorhin die rede aber dann
müsste man es gar nicht so darstellen
als wäre es ein therapeutikum oder
hättest den zweck das bewusstsein zu
erweitern sondern ist es einfach der
ausstieg herscheid egger naja ich glaube
nicht dass es sinn macht quasi diese
rauschzustände zu nutzen um eben zu
fliehen
ich sehe bisschen das risiko darin dass
sie hat enorme intensitäten in sich
tragen und durch diese starke intensität
letztlich den blick auf die autos
realität auch ein stückweit verzehren
ich denke das bewusstsein nicht so
skalierbare ähnlich wie ein mikroskop
wurde je weiter wir
zoomen oder umso stärker wir uns in
intensitäten begeben
umso weniger erkennen wir eigentlich wie
berauschend auch die alltagsrealität
sein kann wie viel schönheit wie viel
besonderheit letztlich auch in den
täglichen dingen drinsteckt und kann
aber das ist jetzt überraschend für mich
von ihnen die sie ja eigentlich
plädieren dafür diese substanzen
zumindest in kontrollierten studien
schon mal zuzulassen sie sagen jetzt
wenn ihr das so oft tun dann verlieren
wir den sinn für das rauschhafte im auto
ich sehe auch die gefahr oder dass die
intensitäten des rausches letztlich auch
eine lehre und eine lange weile
hinterlassen können oder dass menschen
die in der lehre oder langeweile drin
sind sich das in diese intensitäten
hinein flüchten und aus psychiatrisch
oder psychotherapeutisch dass ich denke
das ist nicht der sinn des rauschens und
er sind des rausches soll seien
letztlich ein stück weit das besondere
im täglichen leben wieder zu erkennen
und wertzuschätzen und auch an unseren
realen beziehungen letztlich zu können
sie nur noch ganz kurz ich das gerne
verstehen möchten nur ein beispiel geben
sie gehen auf einem lsd-trip keine
ahnung sie haben 1000 blumen und sterne
und die welt um an sie und so weiter was
genau lernen sie jetzt für den alltag
die schönheit quasi in den alltäglichen
dingen zu sehen wenn ich in der natur
draußen bin beispielsweise die blüten
einer blume sehr zu schätzen
aus einem symbol oder für das leben und
es schärft mir quasi den blick wie der
lebensprozesse ich manifestiert und in
welchen formen mit sich selbst
kommuniziert ja ich finde wir müssen
vielleicht nochmal genauer gucken
welcher rausch ist denn in ordnung also
was gibt es denn für rausch formen wo
man wo man sich darauf einigen kann das
ist okay ist oder anders gefragt
an welchen punkten macht es unsere
heutige gesellschaft schwer genau diese
formen des rausches auch zu leben und
was mir vorhin zb bei dieser statistik
einfiel dass jetzt noch nicht raus aber
dieses wer trinkt jeden tag alkohol wer
ist abhängig und die grenzen der
abhängigkeit oder sagen wir mal des
pathologischen alkoholgenusses die
werden ja immer enger gezogen
also ich hab mal irgendwo gelesen jemand
der jeden tag ein glas bier trinkt ist
eigentlich quasi schon abhängig weil er
ja jeden tag ein glas bier trinkt ich
bin eine sehr überzeugte feierabendbier
trinkerin ich trinke jeden abend ein
bier- und das lasse ich mir auch nicht
nehmen dieses bier will ich trinken und
die mir hilft das irgendwie in diesen in
diesen feierabend gegenüber zu wechseln
der zweite punkt ist ich finde es gibt
zwei formen des rausches jetzt im
engeren sinne
die ich sehr befürworte der einen rausch
das ist der eigentlichen rausch der sich
um verfügbar ein stellt er sich zufällig
einstellt ich glaube dass wir heute ja
in einer kultur leben wo wir selbst den
rausch sehr genau planen wollen ja durch
weiß dass ich google maps irgendwelche
daten
man verabredet sich es muss alles
irgendwie stimmen dazu gehört finde ich
auch das micro dasing also man ist das
ist alles genau geplant und so weiter
aber der tollste rausch ist doch der wo
man eigentlich nichts erwartet und
plötzlich wird es grandios einfach mit
anderen und das dritte das dritte moment
ist eigentlich der wirklich innere auch
in rituale eingefasste rausch also
karneval
bei mir war es das schützenfest sowohl
leute einfach vier tage zusammen sind
und es ist es gelten ganz andere die
eigentlich einem ritualisierten rauschen
das ist das beste stichwort um zum
nächsten thema zu kommen es ist ja so
dass in vielen mystischen traditionen
der rausch eine ganz große rolle spielt
zum beispiel christentum oder im islam
wird auch gegen erhält zu gott innerhalb
eines rauschhaften erlebnisses
zelebriert und in der nähe zu gott
offenbar kann man sich vollkommen auf
lesen ja bei mir ist jetzt peter husain
kunz ein islamischer mystiker und
schlichtes maybe ordens hier in der
schweiz
koons haben wir in rauschzuständen
zugang zu einer anderen art von realität
vielleicht sogar zu etwas göttliches
absolut für die chance verstehe ich es
eine situation wo ich einfach weg fehlt
mal voll von hier
ich will wo anders sein ich hab das was
ich hier erlebe und bin das genügt mir
nicht ich muss ab und zu mal weg von da
und das machen wir ganz gezielt ab und
zu mal weg von da also mit den grenzen
die wir organisieren und die wir selbst
pflegen ist dass einmal ein aktuellen
momentanes weg von hier genau und diese
dreh tänze die ist jetzt erwähnt haben
die schauen wir uns kurz an sie sind sie
haben früh zum islam gefunden muss man
sagen
1967 sind seit 20 jahren schon so was
wie ein arzt oder ein lehrbeauftragter
in diesem metier wie orten der geht
zurück auf einen islamischen mystiker im
dreizehnten jahrhundert rooney heißt er
und wie diese drehten sie ausschauen das
schauen wir uns jetzt mal gemeinsam an
[Musik]
das ganze findet statt hier in einer
kirche in zürich und man sieht schon es
ist ein ritual traditionelle gewänder
man sieht hier sie im bild mit diesem
speziellen hut sie leiten diese
zeremonie
was ist denn das zu dieser drehten sie
wo will man hin
also wir orientieren unsere monotheismus
das ist judentum christentum und islam
und tourismus ist teil des islams und
das ist monotheistische orientierung ich
sage mal gerne orientieren
ich vergleiche und sie sich deswegen ich
mich nicht mit buddhisten und anderen
orientierungsmöglichkeiten und wir sagen
dass die st das ist dieser zustand wo
warum und zeit herrschen wo wir
gefangene von raum und zeit sind und da
wie fühlen sie uns immer nur halb weil
wir wissen oder fühlen dass es noch eine
andere welt gibt das traditionell
jenseits genannt wird
ich nenne es gern das hintergründige das
heißt bei allem was wir sehen erkennen
in dieser welt auch mit forschung und
allem wenn wir die augen haben zu sehen
dann sehen wir weiter noch etwas
hintergründiges und in dieser drehung
erlebt man einen zugang zu diesem
hintergründigen zu diesem jenseitigen ja
es ist eigentlich ein weg zum
esoterischen herz nach unserem modell
oder nach unten so vorstellen auf uns
orientierung ist diese satirische herz
der punkt wo es zur jenseitigen drüber
geht und das kann sich ein meditativer
prozess in dieser mitte und wenn ich
dort bin dann öffnet sich die tote store
zu ahnden welt was man kommt in die
eigene mitte er wohl aber verliert
irgendwie auch das eigene ich in diesem
zustand also der jahres ist das ist das
ziel ist eigentlich dass ich von meinem
ich wegkomme
der normale mensch steht auch ein
normaler mensch natürlich haben die
sogenannte normale menschen die wollen
selbstbewusstsein ihrig stärken
da stehen vor allem wir alle wollen
jemand sein
und wenn wir uns beobachten beobachten
wir uns doch wie stark machen wir alle
unsere handlungen davon abhängig dass
wir irgendeine art anerkennung bekommen
sichtbarkeit bekommen
wir wollen uns stärker und die ganze
musik seite scheine eine umkehrung sagen
ich muss von diesem ich heftigkeit
wegkommen
ich muss nicht mehr jemand sein wollen
um es extrem zu sein
meister eckhart dieser christlichen
mystik sprach vom endt werden zum
beispiel so ein konstrukt eines ein wie
ein ein wort ein deutsches wort and
werden also dieser prozess vom weg
kommen von diesem ich hafte das klingt
für mich als laie aber auch nahe beim
buddhismus dass das ego dass ich eine
fiktion ist dass man das in diesen
mystischen erfahrungen auch er kennt
erlebt das ist ganz nahe beim buddhismus
ich hab' ich komme sehr gut zurecht wie
buddhisten nach nachdem gemeinsame
sachen es ist einfach so dass wir das
diesseits ebenso gleichwertig bewerten
wie das jenseits versehen sei nicht
besser als das diesseits also es ist
einfach wie sie nur halb wenn wir nur
das diesseits erkennen und in dieses
leben wollen wenn wir unsere unseren ja
um sowohl nur an unsere wohl denken dann
bitte fest in der zeit gebunden und das
jenseits ist nicht etwa einfach nur das
schöne es ist nicht nur das gute
jenseits des jenseits hat nicht nur ein
sondern auch teufel also jenseits ist
einfach die andere seite der münze wir
sagen gott hält diese münze in der hand
das ist noch größerer seine schöpfung
und die abgründige dunkle seite erfährt
man auch wenn man in diesen mystischen
bewusstseins zuständen ist ja das kann
man ja sowieso ja das kann man sehr wohl
und die aufgabe einer religion oder
einer mystischen tradition ist ja gerade
dass wir wie ordnet und geschützt diese
grenzübergänge hinkriegen und in
gemeinschaft auch gemeinschaft ist ein
schutz
das ist schon ein schutz an sich als die
gemeinschaft ist ein mittel um geschützt
zu sein
die zugehörigkeit in einen schützenden
geschützten rahmen
es geht darum dass ich loslassen kann
wer kann loslassen ohne geschützt zu
sein
ohne die gewissheit zu haben ich komm
ich hab sie gehört wieder nach hause und
so weiter dabei wirke dadurch
kontrollmechanismen oder wir verlassen
uns auf etwas das nicht trägt die
gemeinschaft soll nicht tragen dass ich
voll loslassen kann so interessant und
es ist auch sehr stark reguliert dieses
dieses ritual lassen wenn man sich die
tänzer als hippies vorstellen dass das
pure gegenteil hier wird sozusagen genau
geregelt gedreht wie eine art von
meditation ja auch sehr stark geregnet
ist bei der vorbereitung haben mich zwei
dinge fasziniert nämlich das ich gelesen
habe dass diese dieses drehmoment dieses
sich drehen
eigentlich gar kein rausch ist sondern
ist ein einklinken ninja eine bewegung
die im ganzen universum da ist vom
kleinsten atom bis zu den galaxien
ja das ist natürlich die eine der
symbolisch die symbolik dieses rituals
rituale war es nicht plötzlich bei der
geburt befohlen worden
das ist entwickelt hat sich entwickelt 2
300 jahre in unserem orden zu dem was es
jetzt ist da ist symbolisch hinein
geschlossen und die ganze technik die
ganze die kleider ist alles nicht etwas
das zurzeit von ruby schon war
zurzeit und romy war spontanes drehen
und er hat das quasi was man schon
kannte dieses drehen
hat das salonfähig gemacht in seinen
kraft seiner bekanntheit und seiner
stärke und sein rad und sie haben wir
ein vorgespräch gesagt wenn man da so
dreht und das geübt hat da hinein ein
meister ist dann machen die erfahrung
dass man selbst plötzlich stillsteht und
die welt dreht sich nicht mehrmals das
ist dann natürlich die erfahrung wenn
jemand das wirklich gut kann da gibt es
momente wo ich gar nicht mehr merke ich
habe das von von nach von evelyne
binsack abi sache aussagen gehört ich
merke gar nicht mehr wie ein angestrengt
ich bin die spitze ich krieche ich fühle
mich völlig in ruhe in und um mich was
die welt herum und ich bin selbst sind
das sind so momente sehr oft ist das so
zwischendurch nicht ganz denn unser weg
ist kein das gibt es nicht ein wow ich
habe es geschafft das gibt's nie unser
weg ist ein unendlicher weg für die auf
und wie sie team auf dem weg
also ist immer ein annäherung denn wenn
wir ganz drin sind schlussendlich dann
verbrennen wir sagt man die jungs also
es ist diese bekannte bild der des
nachteil dass der um die kerze flattert
weil er vom licht angezogen ist ein
trinker dann ist er verbrannt das wäre
der tod aber eben es ist sozusagen ein
wie ein versuchsweise ein tor das ich
loszulassen ein sterben bevor man
wirklich stehen also ist die alte mystik
auch angelus silesius der christliche
möglichkeit das gesagt wer nicht stirbt
bevor er stirbt vor der abwehr stirbt
sehr schön sie waren ja das leben lang
eigentlich ein suchender und bevor sie
auf den religiösen weg gekommen sind
sind sie mit langen haaren in den 60er
jahren und barfuß drei jahre lang um
gelaufen waren eine richtige hippie und
haben den rausch so gesucht haben ja
auch drogen genommen was war das für
eine erfahrung
das war rückblickend ist vor allem eine
erste erfahrung also ich habe nur ich
habe nicht stark habe ich hatte ab und
zu ich war ab lsd konsumiert mit
freunden und was mir da auch noch heute
als lehrreiche erinnerung ist ist eben
dass die countryband nicht nur gut ist
otto bock schwarzlicht und schwarze
seiten im jenseits also ich habe aus
meiner erfahrung öffnen sich die tore
zum ihren sites mit sachen drogen und
wenn ich nicht vorbereitet bin nicht
wirklich kommt einfach das auch nicht so
was irgendwie mehr platz findet ich habe
da wirklich ein frank gehabt der hat
immer schlechte oder fast über schlechte
trips gehabt ist so leid wird dann auch
in der psyche gelandet und ich habe
immer nur gute gehabt warum denn das
wir waren freunde wir haben zusammen
dinge gemacht er lebte und ich erlebe
santos und sie würden sagen dass
verstärkt etwas was schon in mir drin
ist ja was ich mir war schon ich
behaupte dass jetzt war schon etwas das
standhaft war dass ich habe die
kontrolle gehört von uns aus philosophin
hier aus das ist für mich auch immer
wichtig gewesen nationaler mensch und
und die liebe zur schönheit der quandts
viel herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
danke
wir haben jetzt schon öfters jetzt
darüber gesprochen in vielen religionen
spielt er raus eine gewisse rolle
es wurde der karneval auch erwähnt auf
ein ritual rituelle rauschzustand in
einer gesellschaft bestimmte tage die
dafür reserviert worden sind mich würde
interessieren herr scheide da kann man
eigentlich so rituelle rauschzustände
einfach von kultur zu kultur
transportieren und vielleicht können wir
das ein bisschen deutlicher machen was
ich meine an dem alle oscar ritual dass
sie mitgemacht haben im rahmen einer
feldstudie was ist also dieser traum
davon war schon die rede zusammen gemixt
aus café staude glaube ich und eine
liane kommt im amazonasbecken vor und
sie waren bei so einem rausch gemeinsam
gefeierten rauschzustand dabei genau als
forscher und arzt hat mich im prinzip
interessiert warum so viele menschen
ausgerechnet in den amazonas reisen um
da an solchen ritualen schamanischen
ritualen mit alaska teilzunehmen was die
motivation und die hoffnung letztlich
ist von menschen was sie sich dafür
hoffen im sinne eines nachlassens von
beschwerden vielleicht eine befreiung
von suchterkrankungen depression und da
bin ich selber hin gereist und habe mir
das vor ort mal angesehen und es war für
mich sehr eindrücklich zu erleben dass
da eigentlich eine ganze kultur um das
alaska herum entstanden ist eine
indigene kultur die
diese medizin eigentlich fast schon als
sakrament verehrt und dann in
zeremoniellen settings eben feiert wo
sich menschen dann nachts treffen und
dann kollektiv eben dieses wasser
einnehmen dann heftige gefühle
hochkommen
teilweise müssen sie sich auch über
geben was sie dann als körperliche
reinigung beschreiben das ganze wird
begleitet von gesängen durch
medizinmänner und am morgen wird dann
die zeremonie aufgelöst
viele teilnehmer fühlen sich
revitalisiert oder haben einsichten
bekommen in persönlicher
lebenszusammenhänge oder auch tiefe
spirituelle erfahrungen gemacht und
jetzt bieten sie sozusagen aber diese
substanz auch an oder sie machen studien
dazu im rahmen eben von
psychotherapeutischen settings also
meine frage wäre kann man denn nun diese
journalistische ritual in einer
gemeinschaft erlebt einfach nehmen und
die ein einzelnes setting in der schweiz
in einem klinik kaum durchführen
als arzt ist meine primäre motivation
menschliches leiden zu lindern und ich
bin auf der suche nach neuen innovativen
therapien
das heißt wenn wirkstoffe von alaska
tatsächlich therapeutisch wirksam sind
dann wäre es eigentlich unnötig diese
nicht auch im westen anzuwenden um
depressionen angststörungen
suchterkrankungen zu leiden
ich denke es macht wenig sinn oder eine
tradition aus einer fremden kultur eins
zu eins in unserer kultur zu verpflanzen
sondern es geht vielmehr um die frage
können wir hier im westen einen kontext
kreieren der für unsere menschen hier
verständlich ist und nützlich ist um die
nützlichen effekte von allem was in
unserer kultur vielleicht auch
zu wenden vielleicht kommen wir trotzdem
auf so eine idee zurück die wir am
anfang schon mal versprochen herzen ging
es nicht ursprünglich in diesen dingen
jetzt mal religiösen formen des rausches
darum die gemeinschaft zu stärken und
die verbundenheit gegen aussen hin zu
erleben mit gott mit der natur
vielleicht mit den tieren währenddessen
ist heute in vielen rauschzuständen um
den tritt nach innen geht sich selber
nahe zu sein sein eigenes bewusstsein zu
erweitern
mir fällt ganz spontan ein wenn sie das
so beschreiben es gibt ja in clubs finde
ich mehr und mehr die unsitte muss man
sagen sich selbst und andere andere
leute während des rauschzustand es zu
filmen also um das dann irgendwie zu
posten oder oder was weiß ich was und
deshalb ist in guten klubs gibt es ja
ein smartphone verbot also man darf
einfach nicht mit dem smartphone
irgendwie so machen also was ich daran
so interessant finde ist ja dass im
moment des rausches wo es eigentlich
darum geht tatsächlich einfach mal sich
selber mal ganz kurz zu vergessen
und irgendwie auch zu gehen auch in
dieser gemeinschaft in mit der man da
vielleicht tanzt oder irgendwie in
gemeinsam raus rauschzustand erlebt in
diesen in diesem klub mauern das
eigentlich verunmöglicht wird durch
diese reflexive distanz das des
smartphones das was es wirklich extrem
erschwert in diesem zustand überhaupt
noch zu kommen
sie hat mir am anfang ihres gesprächs da
auch gesagt sie sind ein richtiger
protest an dass ihnen scheint wenn schon
raus wichtig zu sein irgendwie religiös
angebunden was wäre denn passiert der
unterschied wenn sie dieses alaska
ritual hören werden sie auch finden sie
sind ja kollegen sozusagen können wir
ruhig hier auch mal durchführen
also ich bin erstmal weiter gas meinung
wenn es um die medizinische
anwendbarkeit geht dann müssen wir diese
substanzen testen ob sie tatsächlich
einen medizinischen nutzen haben und das
passiert derzeit und das finde ich sehr
sehr gute idee erstmal nicht beschäftigt
ja eher der der rauschzustand außerhalb
medizinische anwendungen
wenn nicht nicht medizinische
anwendungen des rausches ansonsten und
da kommt mir natürlich schon der
eindruck dass gerade die psychedelic
adidas der zeit der renaissance erleben
nicht nur in der psychiatrie sondern
auch in der gesellschaft zb wars katze
können dass das so eine form von pará
spiritualität ist ja also wir haben wir
haben eine religiöse entkernung in den
letzten 30 40 50 jahren erfahren
aber die sehnsucht nach spirituelle
erfahrungen die ist natürlich geblieben
und die füllen wir jetzt auf unter
anderem bezeichnen zu können und ein
kollege der sich auch mit dem thema
beschäftigt hat mir erzählt dass
irgendwo in holland tausende von leuten
auf alaska zu den klängen einer
wunderbar und der wunderbaren welt der
amelie plötzlich auf den tripp gehen wo
ich denke wie pervertiert ist diese
kulturelle aneignung in dem moment in
meinen augen des awards daraus dass ich
sie kurz fragen woher nehmen sie ihre
wertung was ist die grundlage dieser
wertung warum ist das passiert
naja ich glaube dass wir tatsächlich
eine kulturelle technik übertragen und
sie aber spirituell letztlich dadurch
entfernt haben da wo diese diese technik
angewendet wird dort gibt es einen
klaren kulturellen rahmen klaren
kulturellen umgang es gibt ein ritus in
denen das eingebettet ist und hier nimmt
man sich einfach einen kleinen teil raus
letztlich den rausch die die veränderung
des bewusstseins und macht die sozusagen
zu einem rein hedonistischen erlebnis
und das finde ich das finde ich erstmal
bemerkenswert die wertung
ja sie haben die wertung raus gehört ich
finde es aber auch irgendwie in gewisser
weise
sie haben vorhin lachen wissen ich bin
okay ist und trotzdem habe ich ja sehr
protestantische erlebt also ich finde es
nicht so schlimm wenn man sich jetzt
eine kultur von irgendwo aneignet und
daran spaß hat ich finde es gefährlicher
die hoffnung die daran kriegt also ich
hab nur im freundeskreis leute die gehen
vor zwei wochen nach südamerika gibt
sich der den teheran fühlten sich
schlecht damit sie sich gut fühlen
können sehr zynisch sehr protestantisch
und kommen zurück und haben diese tiefe
erfahrung und diese tiefen weisheiten
und da geht es jetzt nicht um
medizinische anwendung oder darum
therapeutisches selbstmedikation da geht
es wirklich um diese spirituelle suche
und man kann das nach sonnenuntergang
bildern auf instagram ausformuliert
sehen und es ist eigentlich meistens
ziemlich banale sorry bullshit aber
verbunden mit dieser tiefen emotionen
die die ihm raus erlebt wurde wird es
plötzlich wichtig nun für einen
spirituellen weg denke ich nicht dass es
eine abkürzung gibt und da bin ich
wieder da das ist wenn jemand sein leben
lang so viel meditation verschiedenster
formen macht und ab und zu ein clips von
etwas anderem erreicht hat das wirklich
überzeugt mich das wenn ich in zwei
wochen
model habe irgendwo kombiniert mit
badestrand vielleicht noch buche und
dann denke ich komme als weiser mensch
zurück
dann denke ich dass es ein bisschen
beschiss herr schneider gar sie sind ja
auch jemand der sich sehr gut auskennt
mit achtsamkeit meditation sie haben
auch das erforscht beherrschen das
selber auch auf eine art 10
buddhistische weltlich gewendete
meditationsform und auch da gibt es
studien wo sie zeigen konnten wenn man
das kombiniert mit psychedelischen
substanzen dann kommt man tiefer in die
meditation in die ruhe in diese
ryan ist das zutreffen was jetzt herr ra
wie sagt ist das ein bisschen so eine
abkürzung die auch wohl wirken kann oder
würden sie sagen nein das ist einfach
nur eine potenzierung des ganzen lasst
uns doch das einfach kombinieren
ich kann man muss unterscheiden zwischen
achtsamkeit als bewusstseins technik und
achtsamkeit aus eine form von
spiritualität wo man dann andere
wirklichkeiten oder wo man gewisse
sehnsüchte oder bedürfnisse letztlich
damit befriedigt und was mich primär
interessiert ist aus achtsamkeit aus
bewusstseins technik das heißt wie gehe
ich mit meinem bewusstsein so um dass
ich beispielsweise unangenehme gefühle
schmerzlich gefühle alles was das leben
zu bieten hat auch integrieren kann
statt es letztlich aus meinem
bewusstsein wegzudrängen indem ich eben
in irgendwelche spirituellen
glaubensrichtungen mich dann hin bewege
was anderes was interessant ist in dem
zusammenhang ist das phänomen der selbst
transzendenz also die fähigkeit
letztlich dass ich bewusstsein
aufzulösen in was größeres einzugehen
und da glaube ich das ist ein phänomen
was in vielen letztlich raus erfahrungen
drin steckt und dass ich nicht nur auf
meditation beschränkt sondern befinden
das eben auch in der psychedelische
erfahrung oder in anderen gipfel
erlebnissen abgang maslow hat das pic
experience is genannt und die frage die
mich als wissenschaftler beschäftigt ist
welche rolle oder welche funktion haben
diese peak experience können diese pick
experience letztlich zu einem
perspektivenwechsel beitragen oder zur
gesundheitsförderung oder persönlichen
weiteren trikot eines menschen
unabhängig davon was sich dahinter noch
versteckt oder ich würde gerne einen
letzten punkt noch aufnehmen den sie
aufgebracht haben darauf lassen wir das
sie haben gesagt es gibt verschiedene
gründe weswegen wir vielleicht den
raussuchen könnten
einer könnte auch sein dass wir uns
fürchten vor den tod das ist war teil
des magerquark es dass wir alle sterben
müssen ist eigentlich furchtbar und
vorhin wurde so wunderschön beschrieben
die eigentlich die meditation diese
mystic einen vorlaufen zum tode ist ein
stück weit ein einüben dass sich lösen
vom eigenen ich und tatsächlich hat die
meditation immer auch dieses moment
betont und interessanterweise hat micro
tollen diesen vorschlag in seinem buch
ganz stark wenn das er sagt lasst uns in
der palliativmedizin als in der
betreuung von schwerkranken sterbenden
menschen auch stärker wieder mit
psychedelic arbeiten um diese angst vor
dem tod überwinden zu können um
erfahrungen zu ermöglichen die nahe sind
am tod vielleicht ganz kurz noch ist das
eine idee der sie sich anschließen
können für die sie sich erwärmen können
oder gilt es das einfach auszuhalten
diese angst erkennung also es gibt sehr
gute studiendaten dazu dazu dass gerade
bei erkrankungen die im tod unmittelbar
mit dem tod bedroht sind
angst zustände durch solche substanzen
stark gemildert werden können warum auch
immer ob da ein spirituelles erlebnis
dahinterstehen zahlreichen gesten sehen
die wasserscheide ja ich denke jede raus
erfahrung ist ja gewissermaßen eine
simulation oder eines sterbeprozess ist
also die person lebt eigentlich in dem
moment oder feiert einen ähnlichen
prozess den sie vielleicht erfährt wenn
sie stirbt und zurück zu kommen
diesen prozess durchgemacht zu haben
kann letztlich auch den respekt die
angst die haltung sowohl dem tod aber
auch dem leben gegenüber vereint
übrigens eine sehr schöne geschichte
dazu ist ja odysseus odysseus der der
diese irrfahrt macht bekanntermaßen und
dann irgendwann an der insel vorbei
kommt wo die sirenen leben und diese
vogel ähnlichen wesen und es ist
vollkommen klar wenn er sich jetzt
diesen gesang einfach so ausliefert dann
wird er sterben wir alle seeleute vorher
auch er wird diesen dieser verlockung
erliegen er wird sterben und deshalb
wendet er den berühmten trick an weil er
zuvor gewarnt wurde durch kirche durch
die göttin und er lässt seinen seeleuten
die ohren verstopfen lässt sich von den
seeleuten wiederum an einen mast binden
lässt sich selbst nicht die ohren
verstopfen weil er den gesang genießen
möchte aber er ist am macht gefesselt
und kann eben nicht seinem drang seinem
trieb gehorchen und zu diesen vogel
ähnlichen wesen wollen und und das ist
glaube ich in dieser geschichte steckt
wahnsinnig viel drin also einmal die die
todesnähe des genießens es gibt bei
freud ja auch den todestrieb also ich
glaube dass tatsächlich auch diese die
sehnsucht danach diese grundspannung des
lebens einfach aufzulösen
es ist einfach auch anstrengend zu leben
so dass das dass das genießen das dass
das natürlich eine weise ist und dass
aber gerade für uns moderne subjekte ist
einfach natürlich eine aufgabe ist die
kontrolle zu behalten und den genuss
genauso weit an sich ran zu lassen dass
ich ihn noch goutieren kann aber eben
nicht erliegen
was sind wir wieder bei der ambivalenz
und wir sind am ende unserer sendung ich
würde gerne schließen mit dem
schlussapplaus diese micro polen buch er
schreibt der geist ist größer und die
welt viel lebendiger als ich anfangs
wusste das gilt auch für mich ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich her kennt nur
dass sich ihr waren erscheinen frau
schröder herr erlaubt vielen vielen
herzlichen dank
[Musik]
ja ganz ganz herzlichen dank von meiner
seite irgendwie im saal und auch ihnen
zu hause und wenn sie vom rausch noch
nicht genug haben
gleich im anschluss zeigen wir den
legendären film viel los in las vegas in
der hauptrolle johnny depp und danach
den spielt die spielfilm delikatesse
requiem for a dream bleiben sie also
dran und verpassten sie nicht das
schlusswort von pedro lenz gehört das
russische der branche der blue stage
neckar und einen dvb h gelost aber
harald oder zurückgestellt wie durch die
gabe klar ausnahmen neue ideen und das
bistro libyens chaplin oder buster bin
und das firmament als flügel im inneren
des spätsommers rust und ruß und rutsche
die augenregion akkustrom fleischkonsums
tempo rufus bluetooth menschen
betrachtet sehe ich sehr billige der
sportwelt der selbstverwirklichung aber
unversehrt wie vor gültig wenn jake
blues roots routes zum natürlichen
normalzustand möchte haye gegen
verstanden unsere arbeit zustande die
ganze welt erobert die ganze welt er hat
die ganze welt erfolg am zweiten schlag
sie den zuschlag für data flat
hildesheim etr steht das team gegen
spezielle ballade brand in pdfs
werkstoff als damals trainierte 77 ps
starken vorbereitung auf den act arra
der blaue von grüne wort verboten
meine wenigen überhaupt drehen jedem
gegenüber steht der party oder auch mal
einen fehler macht man ein quartier oder
dorffest straße künftig zehn minuten
anschauen
oder als single malt er hofft im lang
singles priebe
cuba libre fresco logic gott überhaupt
charango die software keine demo kommt
mit blüte ist langsamer verlaufen vor
besonders synapse vorbild folgen der
wahl o mat drin ist die größe und
schwarz ich warum machen die das ufer
sie komplex zu hören das frühstück dort
zur wiener schiff dem sommer zur wwdc
tages russische kruse das wochenende
steht wenn man ihn fragt er vor ort die
cd s bahn verfolgt wie der bahnhof
vorsorge dafür jede kleine fressen was
ist der niedrigste kurs minimal von otto
h das rutschen trust & blues und roots &
fashion branche
[Applaus]